uno informe de la organización global
witness se reveló que en 1733 personas
defensoras del medio ambiente fueron
asesinadas en los últimos 10 años el 68%
se encuentra en América Latina México es
el país más peligroso del mundo para los
defensores medioambientales registrando
Un aumento significativo en la violencia
contra los activistas del país que
buscan proteger la tierra y nuestros
recursos saludamos a Francisca de
estuardo y es asesora para la campaña de
personas defensoras de la tierra y el
medio ambiente en global witness Gracias
Francisca por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de viernes en directo América la
situación de Los Defensores del medio
ambiente en la tierra y la tierra Perdón
en el mundo en general demos un panorama
general Para ya irnos a nuestra región
bueno
la organización viene documentando desde
hace 10 años la situación de las
personas defensoras de la tierra y el
medio ambiente sobre todo lo que
respecta a los asesinatos en este
sentido hemos encontrado como como bien
dices que más de 1700 personas han sido
asesinadas en los últimos en los últimos
años en la mayoría de los casos estos
asesinatos no se dan en un contexto
aislado sino que se dan más bien en en
la interjección de distintos factores
como la impunidad
la falta de independencia de los poderes
regulaciones que son regresivas para la
sociedad civil empresas que son abusivas
se genera todo un clima que habilita que
estos asesinatos ocurran con mayor con
mayor
facilidad y con menores consecuencias y
lo que hace que también se sea más fácil
de que se repitan en un futuro
que en general al menos los casos que
hemos documentado las personas que
fueron asesinadas
antes habían recibido ataques O sea no
es solamente el asesinato digamos es una
una etapa que va más allá pero que se
podría detener antes si hubiera medidas
apropiadas para poder hacerlo sabemos
que América Latina sigue siendo un foco
importante pero también vemos casos que
nos preocupan muchísimo en Asia por
ejemplo en Filipinas que sigue siendo un
país que aparece una y otra vez en las
normas en estos rankings Y que ahora
también tiene un gobierno que es mucho
más conservador
vemos también estas situaciones en India
también vemos en África como las
personas que son guardaparques y que
protegen estos ecosistemas son atacadas
mortalmente entonces vemos que esto
estos asesinatos en Más allá de su
sumatoria son personas son familias son
comunidades las que se ven afectadas
Pero además de eso
vemos que hay patrones que cruzan estos
asesinatos en los distintos puntos en
los que hemos podido investigar claro
Francisco
los gobiernos digamos y las autoridades
le prestan atención y se toman con todas
las ayudas de estas amenazas que tienen
previa estos líderes medioambientales
pues seguramente No llevaría a su
lamentable asesinato Pero ahora sí vamos
a enfocarnos en la región de América
Latina y del Caribe Porque todos estos
asesinatos franciscal 68%
aproximadamente se encuentran en nuestra
en nuestra región no porque América
Latina y el Caribe sigue siendo la más
peligrosa región para los defensores de
la Tierra
bueno América Latina ha sido como bien
dices consistentemente una región en
donde se concentran los asesinatos que
hemos documentado hay distintos hay
distintas causas o distintos factores
que aceleran esta violencia por una
parte vemos que es una de las regiones
más desiguales del mundo Esto hace que
haya una concentración de los poderes de
muy pocas manos y por el otro lado
muchas personas en una situación muy
vulnerable y esto lo vemos en distintos
planos pero la defensa de la tierra y el
medio ambiente hace que finalmente las
personas que son las más afectadas por
la crisis climáticas son las que menos
herramientas tienen para detenerla
entonces vemos Que en América Latina Por
una parte tenemos una región que es rica
en recursos naturales por otra parte
tenemos una tradición indígena
muy fuerte por otra parte tenemos una
serie de organizaciones de la sociedad
civil que han trabajado durante años
para reconocer esto esto estos sistemas
estos biomas los ecosistemas y por otra
parte tenemos gobiernos que han
encontrado en la matriz del
extractivismo
una forma de llevar adelante su entre
comillas desarrollo entonces vemos que
las personas que están en los
territorios no tienen derecho a la toma
de decisión no tienen acceso a los
espacios de toma de decisión y las
autoridades desoyen esta esta
recomendaciones y también las
tradiciones que muchas veces los pueblos
indígenas tienen y que tienen mecanismos
que han sido históricos para poder
preservar Estos espacios entonces vemos
que hay un choque y Digamos como dos
mundos que no se encuentran que las
autoridades que se deberían proteger y
deberían ser las garantes de estas de
estos derechos más bien se encargan de
atacar a las personas de personas
entonces hemos hecho por otra parte
vemos alto estas tasas de corrupción
vemos espacios cívicos cerrados vemos
mucha penetración de empresas
transnacionales que además
desde sus estructuras son muy difíciles
de mapear y de entender digamos dónde
reside la responsabilidad y vemos
también un discurso que es a favor de
este tipo de desarrollo sin escuchar las
consecuencias que eso tiene sobre los
territorios porque México hablando de
territorios es el más peligroso en
nuestra región para los líderes el
medioambientales
bueno México ha experimentado un alza de
los ataques en los últimos años Eso sí
podemos decirlo nosotros no podemos
decir con certeza que los números que
tenemos son los números que existen y
esto básicamente Porque existe una falta
de registro de los ataques y que los
asesinatos se hacen muy visibles O sea
hay regiones en donde cuesta mucho
documentar hay regiones también a las
que cuesta mucho ingresar nosotras lo
vimos cuando intentamos ingresar por
ejemplo para documentar el caso de Peña
colorada la conflictividad de la zona la
presencia del narco hace que sea muy
difícil para las comunidades de salir de
ahí para otras personas llegar ahí
conocer lo que está pasando y poder
digamos involucrarse en un proceso de
toma de decisión de búsqueda de
soluciones para estos problemas eso lo
vemos ahí muy claro vemos que hay un
porcentaje importante de personas que
pertenecen a comunidades y pueblos
indígenas que fueron atacadas letalmente
y esto también no no no nos da una
alarma muy muy importante sobre la
situación en la que se encuentran hoy
estas naciones que son
que llevan años que tienen tradiciones y
que además lo que buscan es el bienestar
Buscar la agricultura pequeña escala
buscan la autonomía y la soberanía sobre
su territorio buscan preservar su
territorio buscan preservar el agua
Entonces digamos son comunidades que más
bien quieren ese territorio para poder
para poder seguir con su proyecto de
vida